amo sto malissimo devo dimenticarlo eh amo
come facciamo dimmi cosa posso fare per te
andiamo a bere una cosa ma dai ma non ho voglia
stasera?
ti prego fallo per me te l'avevo detto che
non era una buona idea andare a bere eh sto
troppo male ma sinceramente secondo te gli
piaccio oppure no?
amo ti avviso in foto effettivamente non viene
benissimo peró dal vivo é troppo bono!
ma stasera tu metti i tacchi?
secondo me mi ha bloccato io me lo sento vai
sul suo profilo e dimmi se mi ha bloccato
amo ma tu ti sei depilata allora amo facciamo
cosí tu adesso leggi questo messaggio e mi
dici cosa ne pensi se per te va bene io glielo
invio subito se c'é anche solo una parola
o qualcosa che non ti convince ci mettiamo
qui e lo riscriviamo perché é importante
ma secondo te mi fa grassa questa felpa?
vabe vado a cambiarmi amo la prossima volta
che mi viene voglia di scrivergli ti do ufficialmente
il permesso di requisirmi il telefono e di
prendermi a schiaffi ti piace questa foto?
la pubblico oppure no?
allora il piano é questo tu adesso vai sul
profilo di questa Claudia e vai a investigare
un pó su di lei ma io voglio che tu vada
indietro negli anni proprio a scavare nel
suo passato se tu mi trovi anche solo un like
di luca io lo lascio se mi gira domani vado
dal parrucchiere e faccio un taglio radicale
oppure faccio prima la frangia e poi le extension
scusa?
cioè gli ha messo tre like e gli ha scritto
un commento sotto una foto dove lei era in
costume?
stavano insieme l'ho sgamato che schifo mandami
gli screenshot adesso lo lascio giurami che
non sei andata a vedere il suo profilo no
forse non hai capito io non gli rivolgerò
mai piú la parola a quel pezzo di merda ma
neanche se mi si presenta sotto casa con un
mazzo di rose beh in quel caso forse NO no
neanche in quel caso hai ragione basta allora
questo lo prendo prendo anche questo ma quella
fucsia dov é?
amo io non voglio intromettermi nella tua
relazione assolutamente non voglio influenzarti
peró sappi che ho un'amica che ha una cugina
che ha una zia che é la vicina di casa della
sorella della madre della nipote della sorella
dell'ex del tuo ragazzo io te la butto lí
se vuoi indagare ci impiego un attimo ma...
il biondino dell'altra sera?
ti ricordi come si chiamava?
aveva un nome un pó esotico tipo Jason Jonathan
Jack amo non hai capito ho trovato tutto il
suo Instagram il suo Twitter il suo Facebook
il suo gruppo sanguigno le sue intolleranze
le sue impronte digitali cioè io sono pazza
lo sooo ma ti dirò di piú non hai capito
cosa ho scoperto che se questo video arriva
a 60 mila like girerò la seconda parte amo?
amo?